hey everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
in today's video we will be taking a
look at controversial mukbanger
nicholas perry better known as nicacato
avocado
now this will not be a what i eat in a
day review video
as nicocado hasn't been doing this
format on his channel
at least not recently aside from of
course his daily mukbangs
so instead we're going to be taking a
look at his channel in general
as well as discussing nicado's
transition from being a
vegan youtuber to a now non-vegan milk
banger
we'll also be discussing themes around
food addiction and the relationship
between
food and mental health and we will later
be joined by eating disorder dietitian
alessandra magisano to dive further into
these topics
but before we start a few quick
disclaimers
number one the information in this video
is for entertainment
and educational purposes only so you
should always speak to a healthcare
provider about your
unique healthcare needs number two this
video is
not intended to diagnose or imply that
nicocado is suffering from food
addiction
an eating disorder or any psychological
distress
the intention of this video is to simply
discuss the themes that i've seen come
up in your dms to me
regarding this youtuber in an
educational and compassionate format
also keep in mind that i'm filming this
video in advance to get ahead before
baby comes
so this may not accurately depict his
diet at the specific moment in time that
you're watching it
and four don't forget to please be kind
in the comments both here and on
nicotto's channels
and five a trigger warning that some
graphics and discussions may be
disturbing to some of my viewers
particularly those who have battled or
are battling disordered eating so
please feel free to skip this video if
that sounds like you
and of course finally don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so you never
miss out on a video
all right so for those of you who are
unfamiliar with nicocado avocados
channel
he is a popular but highly controversial
mukbanger here on youtube
he posts a mukbang video almost every
single
day across all three of his channels
which have collectively amassed
close to 3 million subscribers
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
the mukbang trend
it originated as a korean video format
where the host consumes
large amounts of food for an audience
now it's since been co-opted by young
youtubers
to become more of an eating challenge or
kind of like an outrageous
cheat day than a virtual communal meal
i have shared my personal thoughts on
the mukbang trend in this video right
here that you can watch
but to summarize my thoughts on this
trend it can be perceived as a bit of a
publicized
and sensationalized food binge which i
don't think is typically
a healthy way to eat now despite the
popularity of mukbangs
and of nicocado's videos there has been
growing concern
online about his health status and his
erratic behavior
as a result of his mukbang diet i'm not
going to show
too many clips just to be sensitive to
him but if you've watched his videos you
probably
do know what i'm talking about whether
or not these emotional outbursts are
real
is really up for debate as many viewers
have speculated that his videos
are dramaticized for views i am
absolutely not going to speculate the
authenticity of
nick's emotions i'm not a psychologist
and i
also think it's just insensitive to even
suggest that his
experience is not legitimate however the
potential health risks
of the frequency and quantity of
nicocado's mukbangs
are nutritionally relevant so let's
begin by talking about
that now first i want to do a quick
refresher on
how nicocado's eating style has really
evolved over time
let's take a quick look
[Music]
ranch
if fruit were to make you fat then
i would also be fat i would look like so
this is what i look like well
i'll show the boy this is what i love
okay so
nicotto started his youtube channel as a
raw vegan
doing more modest plant-based milk bangs
however
back in 2016 he released a series of
videos explaining that he
no longer wanted to be vegan largely
because he
really felt isolated and kind of bullied
by
vegans online he also claimed to have
experienced some
negative health effects from his raw
vegan diet including things like hair
loss
tooth decay vitamin b12 deficiency
hypoglycemia
impaired memory and concentration as
well as stating that it was
detrimental to his mental sanity
now because of this he ultimately came
to the conclusion that humans
are designed to eat meat now this more
or less follows the same
sentiments that i've seen from other
vegan youtubers who have likewise
come to express their decision to just
no longer be vegan anymore
i've actually talked about my thoughts
on this no longer vegan trend
at length in my video right here but
similar to other former vegan youtubers
nick felt conflicted about putting his
health before his
moral beliefs while he had shared that
he still
believes in vegan ideologies veganism
just
didn't make him physically feel good
which of course prompted him to
completely change his diet and lifestyle
now if you are currently raging behind
your screen about nick's conclusion that
humans
are designed to eat meat please
let's not start a debate that is not
what this video
is about if being vegan did not feel
good
for nick's mental or physical health
i think that is something that everyone
should just respect so
please let's just move on what i do want
to explore however
is if the decision to be no longer vegan
actually improved his health
or did he just swap one way of eating
that was not serving his health out for
an equally and potentially even
more problematic one let's talk about
the impact of these frequent mukbangs on
one's physical health
now ever since nicocado reintroduced
meat and other animal products into his
diet
he gained notoriety for his outrageous
mukbang
videos they have gradually grown in
quantity
and frequency and are usually made up of
often demonized foods like burgers
pizzas
french fries etc let's take just a
quick look oh my gosh i'm so excited
cheers
to a wonderful eating show
i'm so excited to try this okay so
trigger warning
i'm about to talk numbers but based on
our calculations
this meal alone provides 6700 calories
365 grams of fat and 15
700 milligrams of sodium we'll talk more
about nick's energy needs and sodium
intake later on in this video
but i want to show this really short
clip just to give you an idea of what
his mukbang spreads usually look like so
nick has been doing these types of daily
mukbangs for the last three
years and over time we are now seeing
the significant
impacts that the style of eating has had
both on his physical health
as well as on his emotional well-being
now one of the physical impacts of his
mukbangs has been his very
public weight gain i'm not suggesting
that this weight gain was good or bad
or even unintentional it's actually not
even clear to me
what his health and weight goals are
in one video i watched he talks about
striving for a 300 pound weight goal
and then celebrating after achieving
this goal yet in other videos he
expresses feeling frustrated with
getting fat not knowing why and wanting
to be as
skinny as he was back in his raw vegan
days again it's really impossible for me
or you to know
which of these concerns are authentic
sensationalized for entertainment
or just a result of one being out of
touch with what feels good to their body
and mind but from a health perspective
his recent weight gain
does place him in the obese category for
bmi
so is that a problem well let's talk
about it
first of all the bmi categories are
highly flawed
and the relationship between weight and
health is controversial at best
having said that we do have strong
research linking obesity
to some negative health outcomes but we
also know that there is research to show
that an individual can be classified as
overweight or obese by bmi standards
and still be metabolically healthy
especially
when incorporating nutritious food and
activity into one's lifestyle
this is why we would never recommend
looking at somebody's body
or just their bmi to judge their
metabolic health
it's a data point but it's just one of
many important data points here
but judging by what we see in nick's
videos and the quality of his diet
it's very possible that his mukbang diet
may be taking a negative toll on his
health
whether that's the result of the weight
gain the diet itself
the stress anxiety or depression related
to this lifestyle
or a combination of any or all of these
things
it is impossible for any of us to
pinpoint really
but let's take another quick look when i
was living in philadelphia
over the summer i had a
that i never told anybody i could sense
what was going
to happen and i my entire left arm
felt like something was lighting it on
fire so much pressure
i could not i started to see spots
i started sweating out of my hands and
my feet
and i was in the basement where it's
cooler we had air conditioning
and my felt
like it was about
and so i got some
that you know you take to relief well
actually
when it comes to that type of stuff so
in this
very vulnerable moment nick shares that
he experienced a heart attack
at the young age of 27 and
that this really scary eye-opening
experience
ultimately made him reconsider the
nature of his mukbang
videos he goes on to express his fear
around the possibility of dying from
this way of eating
but is really conflicted because this is
ultimately how he
earns a living now i genuinely feel
so sad and empathetic that nick is in a
position
where he feels the need to sacrifice his
emotional and physical well-being
in order to not only entertain his
audience
but to maintain financial stability
he himself has even said that he's
willing to put his life and health on
the line
just for some views and while nick's
career choice and niche is
obviously very unique i think a lot of
people can relate to the sentiment of
doing something
that maybe they know doesn't support
their health
but they feel unable to stop because
it's what puts food on the table
even just thinking about some people
during this whole pandemic who
have had to put themselves in risky work
scenarios to support their family
i'm sure a lot of people feel that they
don't always have a choice
and perhaps that's how nick feels too
now at the end of this video which was
published
back in april 2020 he declares that he
will be going back to veganism
for a year in order to lose weight and
improve his health
so is this the right choice well from a
nutrition perspective
there are definitely a ton of health
benefits of eating plant-based which
i've spoken to ad nauseam on the channel
already but when it comes to heart
health specifically
research does show that a plant-based
diet can lower the risk of heart disease
and other risk factors like blood
pressure and cholesterol
so from my perspective as a dietitian
thinking just about the physiological
benefits for a minute
eating more plant-based foods may help
nick better support
his young heart but like all diets a
vegan diet can be done in a
nutritionally
balanced way and also one that is
arguably potentially
just as problematic as the mukbang
regime
let's take a look i want to use what i
have here
for good and i want to show people a
healthy way to eat
this is my breakfast lunch and dinner
for the next
week
this is more exciting for me and it's
more variety
okay so nick plans to eat a total of 35
bananas a day to add
variety and help him lose weight again
i need to preface this with the fact
that just days after this video went
live
he uploaded a series of non-vegan
mukbang videos
where he was eating a 21 pound lobster
in one
and cheesy noodles in another so we just
don't actually know
if any of this reflects his true
intentions or is
just for the show but i can only comment
on
what i've seen and heard and since
viewers may also
casually just see one or two videos here
or there
i do want to take the time to discuss it
so for education's sake 35 bananas a day
adds up to about 3 672 calories
107 grams of fiber 45 grams of protein
943 grams of carbs
and 14 785 milligrams of potassium
so according to our calculations the
calories derived from this amount of
bananas
would actually exceed the estimated
amount of calories so
around 2700 or so that he would need to
maintain his current weight never mind
to lose
yes his typical mukbangs do provide
significantly more energy
around 5000 to 10 000 calories per
sitting
and all of these predictive equations
are just
estimations not an accurate depiction of
an individual's
real true needs so it's possible that
nick's energy needs
may in fact be much less or much more
than what was estimated but either way i
think that we can all agree
that getting almost twice one's calorie
needs in
one food alone is not a sustainable
balanced or healthy way to eat this is
not what i would call adding variety so
even though i think adding fruit to his
diet
is a positive change for nick this would
not help nick meet his overall nutrient
needs
just eating bananas for example would
leave him deficient in
a ton of nutrients like calcium fat
vitamin d
iodine iron and zinc just to name a few
and since this raw vegan style of eating
caused him to
experience some negative health outcomes
in the past i wouldn't
want him starting off again on the wrong
foot only to realize that he just can't
maintain this lifestyle
and then swinging the pendulum back to
the other extreme again
shunting back and forth between two
unsatisfying diet extremes
is not typically how we achieve a
healthy
moral free and balanced relationship
with food
let's see what he has to say about his
new mono meal diet
aka just eating one food in his day
this is health this
is health this is fiber
this is potassium to push out all that
sodium i will be adding salt to this
okay so let's talk about this plan here
by eating 35 bananas in a day
nick is getting close to 300 percent of
his daily fiber recommendation
and fiber has been shown to help reduce
cholesterol levels
and other risk factors for heart disease
like blood pressure
and while someone who has been eating a
general balanced diet
and transitioning to a more plant-based
eating way
over time may be accustomed to greater
fiber levels
nick has predominantly been getting his
calories from fat
and refined carbohydrates that are low
in fiber
so he is like ramping up the fiber
intake really
super fast this rapid increase in fiber
can cause digestive discomfort like gas
bloating and constipation
so ideally we would want to gradually
increase fiber intake to allow the
digestive system to adjust
so that he doesn't experience unpleasant
symptoms and then
understandably want to throw in the
towel he also talks about wanting to
consume more potassium to help
push out all that sodium so to recap
he's getting close to
15 000 milligrams of potassium from
these bananas which
is more than 400 percent of his
potassium needs for the day
so this of course does sound like a lot
of
potassium however high potassium intakes
are not usually considered to pose a
significant health risk
unless somebody has impaired kidney
functions
or in some elderly populations as the
kidneys become
less efficient at removing potassium
from the blood
but since he assumedly doesn't have
these issues
it's pretty low risk to get a lot of
potassium from food
alone as for its ability to push out the
sodium
well in layman's terms this is in fact
true
so one of the many reasons why a diet
rich in fruits and vegetables is so
heart healthy
is because they're common sources of
potassium
and potassium does help excrete excess
sodium from the body
which helps to lower blood pressure
potassium also helps to relax
blood vessel walls which further
contributes to lowering blood pressure
and ideally for those who are at greater
risk of heart disease
it's important to try to make changes to
when sodium and potassium
intake together one two part trial found
that
just lowering salt intake or just
increasing potassium intake
was not as effective at fighting
hypertension
or heart disease as doing both together
having said that we don't want to have
no sodium in our diet either as salt
also plays an important role in muscle
contraction and fluid balance like
like what nick is saying so we actually
don't have an official recommended
dietary
ratio but i've seen numbers in the
literature recommending an ideal sodium
to potassium intake ratio
of about one to three meaning our
potassium intake
should ideally be around three times our
sodium intake but if all one ate was
bananas
you'd be looking at a ratio of 422
to one so in this case even though i'm
not sure it's the most appetizing
combination
adding a little salt to the bananas
might help offset this extreme imbalance
or you know
just eating a greater variety of foods
which would have a multitude of other
benefits as well
but as a segway from salt let's talk
about
water weight so one of nick's most
common catch phrases when referring to
his weight gain
is saying it's just water weight in fact
he now sells his own line of merch
adorned with the phrase so again we're
not sure if he's just joking when he
says this
or if he legitimately believes that his
weight is attributed to
water weight but for educational
purposes let's talk about water weight
for a hot minute
so water weight essentially refers to
fluid retention
in the body which causes bloating
swelling and
puffiness one of the most common causes
of water weight gain
is a high sodium diet often
as a result of ultra processed foods we
know that in an
average nakakato avocado mukbang that
nick would be getting between
five thousand and fifteen thousand
milligrams of sodium
which is between two to six times the
suggested amount
research suggests that the amount of
water retention one experiences
from a salty meal can definitely vary
and depends on how far sodium intake is
from baseline
or what's normal for the person but in
terms of water weight
most people are looking at an uptick of
around two pounds on the scale
carbohydrates can also contribute to
water weight retention
since for every one gram of carbs you
consume your body needs about three to
four grams of water to process
and store it so in nick's typical
mukbangs there's
no shortage of refined carbs so
depending on how many carbs one consumes
that could add on a few extra pounds as
well but taken together
we're talking about somewhere in the
neighborhood of five
extra pounds not something that would
necessarily even change
your pant size so yes certain foods can
cause fluctuations on the scale
but unless there's something
physiologically wrong like heart failure
severe protein deficiency liver damage
or kidney damage
some kind of digestive issue it's likely
not a hugely
significant amount now in terms of
reducing
water retention you can consume more
potassium-rich foods and
no it does not have to be 35 bananas
like nick is suggesting
uh you can also drink more water go for
some exercise
reduce your intake of salt and refine
carbohydrates as well as increase your
magnesium intake
from things like nuts whole grains and
leafy greens
so with that said let's now discuss the
potential impacts
that nicotto's mukbang diet has had on
his emotional
and mental health i just want to let you
guys know
that i am not mentally well
i'm not okay
and i'm gonna lose him if i don't get
help
i think that i don't think
i'm made for youtube i don't think that
youtube's for me anymore
just get help from my sick sick mind
that's going crazy from all this junk
food so
nick cotto has plenty of footage in his
mukbang videos where he displays
very strong emotional outbursts and
erratic behavior
he has also previously mentioned that he
does try to capitalize on more dramatic
and emotionally turbulent content as
they generate the highest number of
views so
like i've been saying we can't say for
certain whether or not these reactions
are in fact real but i do want to be
sensitive to whatever emotional
and mental struggles nicocado may be
experiencing
so i'm not going to be showing too many
of those delicate
moments but clearly from these clips you
know
you can see him reaching out because
he's struggling
now one thing i do want to comment on is
nick's suggestion that
junk food has had a negative impact on
his mental well-being
later on in this video he talks about
quitting youtube because his weight is
spiraling out of control
and that even though he feels hungry
he's only going to eat air
for the day i'm of course not a mental
health professional and i'm not here to
diagnose
nick at all but what i'm seeing from
this channel
i can understand totally why his
audience is concerned
for his well-being as he does appear to
be stuck between a rock and a hard place
when it comes to managing both his
health and his youtube career
with that said what i can talk about is
the research
and whether or not junk food really does
have a negative
impact on our mental health now while we
don't know what
nicotto is eating off-screen his typical
mukbang diet where he's not going vegan
is predominantly made up of
calorie-dense
processed foods that are high in refined
carbohydrates
and unhealthy fats and also low in fiber
and antioxidants not only does this have
the potential
to impact his physical health but
research suggests
one's diet may also impact one's mood
one 2019 meta-analysis that looked at 45
000 participants found that increasing
whole foods
and decreasing processed foods can
reduce feelings of anxiety and
depression
there's also some interesting research
to show that individuals who
regularly consume fast food are 51
percent
more likely to develop depression the
researchers
in this study found that the
relationship between
these types of foods and mood is really
dose dependent
meaning that the more you consume the
greater the potential risk
of course there's just also the
possibility that people who consume more
fast food have other socioeconomic
circumstances that
also make them more prone to mental
health issues or
put another way what comes first
depression
or the poor diet thankfully researchers
have
tried to somewhat address this in some
of their studies one large analysis
looked only at
prospective studies so they looked at
the baseline diet and then calculated
the risk of participants developing
depression
down the line the findings suggested
that a higher quality diet
was associated with a lower risk for the
onset of depressive symptoms
but that ultimately more randomized
control trials would be needed
to really control for all of these tiny
little confounders now we also have
research looking at the importance
of the brain gut axes aka the role of
the gut microbiome
in anxiety and depression and for this i
spoke again to my colleague andrea hardy
now we know that consuming high amounts
of ultra-processed foods
can negatively impact the bacterial
composition of our gut
and while we don't have a consensus
necessarily on
which specific bacteria are associated
with depression
we know that there is a link and we also
have research to suggest that
probiotic supplementation may actually
help improve
anxiety and depression there is still a
lot
to uncover in this world but it's
definitely a really
interesting area of evolving research as
for general emotional stability and
cognitive function
research suggests that increased intakes
of trans fats
can increase feelings of irritability
aggression
and negatively affect our ability to
emotionally regulate
other studies have found that eating a
high fat nutrient poor diet for a period
of as little as five days can impair
attention
memory and mood so based on all of this
imperfect science
eating more whole foods may help support
one's emotional health
that's not to say that having a pizza on
a friday night is going to give you a
mental breakdown
if you generally have a healthy diet
while we do
actually see changes in the microbiome
pretty quickly based on what it's fed
that also means that it can bounce back
to normal
pretty fast too so as andrea says what
happens to my gut microbiome in vegas
doesn't stay in vegas ultimately though
it's all about one's long-term dietary
pattern
in nick's case particularly in his
mukbang phases
i would be concerned that his dietary
pattern may play a role in his current
state of mind
now you know my style i don't usually
like to focus on what one needs to
remove from their diet
but rather it's also important to
consider what we can
add to improve health as well so for
example
research has shown that omega-3 fats can
not only help prevent and treat anxiety
and depression
but it can also help improve some mental
disorders
and protect against cognitive impairment
so you can find
omega-3s in foods like fatty fish
walnuts flax
and supplements so that might be a nice
option to work in there with his bananas
finally let's talk about our last theme
here
food addiction and binge eating behavior
again i just want to reiterate that i am
in no way
diagnosing or implying that nick has any
kind of
food addiction or binge eating disorder
i simply want to use this as a teaching
moment to provide some education and
insight
on these topics since they've come up to
me in your questions a lot
and i think that nick's content provides
an interesting segue into some of these
themes
so for those of you who are followers of
nicocado's content
you may be aware that he has repeatedly
vowed to quit
mukbangs and change his diet only then
to return a day later
and despite repeatedly recognizing that
this eating pattern
is problematic and potentially
detrimental to his health
it would appear that he is unable to
quit
these behaviors here's the thing
everyone's saying to eat better
but when i eat better i feel so much
worse
so much worse i'd have any problems in
chicago or in canada with carly but now
that
i've been eating really healthy like
home-cooked meals
proteins healthy fats all this kind of
stuff i feel
disastrous okay so in this clip he
mentions that
even when he does try to eat healthier
he ends up feeling
so much worse an experience that some
people may characterize
as withdrawal now i've talked about this
in my video on food addiction which you
can watch
the whole thing right here but
ultimately
the research on food addiction is pretty
controversial
while there is some research to suggest
that the brain does not react the same
way to food withdrawal
as it does cocaine withdrawal there is
other research to suggest that there may
still be some effect
on the brain and overall mood when
abstaining from certain foods
one 2018 study on 231 participants
found that when individuals cut down on
junk food
they reported feeling tired irritable
and sad
while also experiencing an increase in
cravings in those first few days
the researchers also found that the more
intense the withdrawal symptom
the less likely the change in eating
would be successful
in the long term however this study only
looked at
self-reported data which doesn't
actually tell us
anything about the brain's response to
withdrawal
on the other hand some animal studies
have examined the brains of rats
experiencing withdrawal from sugar and
they found that the dopamine levels in
their brains
dropped and they also exhibited changes
in blood pressure and heart rate
so at this point it's hard to know what
is going on
but i am really empathetic to the fact
that
this is likely an uncomfortable and
stressful transition
especially given how extreme his diet
shifts
seem to be this is generally why i don't
advocate for making any major changes to
one's diet
all in one go going from a 5 000 calorie
fast food diet to a raw vegan diet
subsisting
on only bananas is probably not
going to feel good physically or
emotionally
to anyone and as a result it's also
likely
not going to be sustained for any
meaningful amount of time
next i want to quickly talk about binge
eating disorder
versus overeating now overeating
occasionally is a normal tendency for
all of us
sometimes a special meal tastes so good
we just don't want to stop
or sometimes we've denied ourselves a
specific food
and then when we get access to it again
we have a hard
time stopping binge eating disorder is
defined
as reoccurring episodes of eating
significantly more food
in a short period of time than what most
people would eat in similar
circumstances
binge eating disorder is defined as
recurring episodes of eating
significantly more food
in a short period of time than what most
people would eat in similar
circumstances
alongside feelings of a lack of control
it's also
actually not uncommon three million men
and five million women
in the united states alone suffer from
this disorder
so to get some more clinical experience
on binge eating
i am joined by my old university friend
alessandra magisano
who is now working as a full-time eating
disorder dietitian
so thank you so much alexander for
joining me
oh my gosh my pleasure i'm so happy to
be here thank you
so how common is it in your practice to
see
people who are dealing with reoccurring
binge eating episodes
um to come from you know like a highly
restrictive
eating diet previously it is extremely
common i would say
that i confidently can say like almost
everybody 95
of the cases that i see clinically come
from highly restrictive
um eating patterns and they swing to
binge eating reoccurring episodes
and even if it's not highly restrictive
um in a very extreme way
it's a restriction in some way
restriction always leads to binge eating
in one way or another um and so it's
highly highly prevalent
and what are your thoughts on the
mukbang trend that we see going around
on social media these days
oh dear that's my thought i just i mean
it's actually horrifying um it's it's
disturbing
it's a little bit it's a lot dangerous
um i think that it's dangerous because
it does
um and i know you've mentioned this too
it just glorifies and you're 100 right
it glorifies
eating disorders so what used to be a
secret thing like the binge eating that
i see clinically is oftentimes this
secret shameful um
really dark episodes where someone would
experience it on their own
binge eating now we're just now not only
is it kind of publicized but they're
inviting an audience and they're it's
they're feeding off of the audience and
you don't know where does eating
disorders stop and end
it's a part of the eating disorder i
think too to get that validation
and to get that that feedback from their
their audience so i think it's very
dangerous that this trend is
is happening um it's glorifying eating
disorders
it's giving light um to eating disorders
and making it look like it's just like a
fun thing to just eat large amount of
food
um when it's extremely dangerous and the
emotional
and impact on mental health is so
critical that that's the part you don't
see when you just watch your you know 20
minute videos of people
totally and what would your suggestion
be for somebody
like nick who expresses discomfort in
the binge episodes
and wants to stop but just finds himself
feeling
even worse emotionally when he does try
to stop
well that would make a lot of sense
actually and so that's kind of what i
what i see all the time is like there's
this need to stop
because it is is you know uncomfortable
but they can't and that's when the idea
of oh this is something that's
completely out of my control
and in some sense becomes that way
because
it's now a giant coping strategy so
binge eating disorder essentially
is a way to cope with uh very difficult
and painful emotions and a lot of times
sometimes trauma right whether it's like
a lot of trauma or little trauma
and so it becomes the mainstream way
that someone feels
safe and so if that's your main copy
strategy
you take that away i mean you can't
survive
so what they're actually really attached
to is the fact that it's their only way
of maybe feeling safe
maybe numbing out the pain numbing out
the anxiety coming out the depression
whatever
so of course they can't stop eating
because if they stop eating they'd have
to feel
and if you have to feel that causes a
whole lot of discomfort
right oh absolutely and on that note
um what is your professional opinion on
the idea of food addiction
is this something real that you see and
or what may people be experiencing when
they kind of experience some of these
symptoms of being addicted to food
addicted to sugar addicted to
certain other kinds of um edible
substances yeah yeah it's a really great
it's a really great question
um in my professional opinion food
addiction and from sort of the
sort of the research that we do have it
isn't a real thing
in the sense of other substances so we
can't relate it to
alcohol or drug addiction um mainly
because you can't sustain we don't
sustain from food in the way that you
can those substances we need it to live
but also because our relationship we can
have a healthy relationship with food
whereas
depending on your relationship with
alcohol or drugs there's no there's no
there's no health
healthy way to have it so food addiction
is
more about the fact that when you eat it
it's a pleasurable experience
and like i was saying it's a coping
strategy so
that becomes what's addictive is the
idea that that is how you cope
is how you have control and when you
feel like you
you um lack control in a lot of areas of
your life
food and the way you eat becomes a big
way to control it
so food addiction is largely
um about that is about a coping strategy
and then you become addicted to needing
that way
of soothing and kind of numbing out but
your brain does sort of experience those
those neurotransmitters and those and
and that experience of
when you eat certain things in a way
that you're going into it to numb
or to cope it does soothe it calms you
down
when you're eating you aren't thinking
about you know the the anxiety that you
have or the other things you've got
going on
so it does kind of like soothe you and
so physiologically
it does kind of feel like a bit of a
like a high
in a sense and so that's what people are
experiencing is your body just trying to
actually help you
cope um and so that's what they're
really experiencing but it's easy to
feel like
i'm addicted because it's always
typically a certain type of food
that's associated with it but that's
only because that's the food that's
associated with your soothing
um but we know that you know it's not
just
the highly high sugar high high fat
processed food because
i've seen people binge on healthy food
as well and they get the exact same
high and the exact same feeling of
addiction or orthorexia comes from that
just that soothing and feeling like
that's their safe place
whether it's mcdonald's or peanut butter
totally interesting
yeah and and in your practice do you see
any significant connections between
somebody's eating behavior and their
mood
so like when you know when we regulate
their eating does mood improve or vice
versa
what are your thoughts absolutely so
it's
highly highly correlated which is why um
bingeing disorder requires sort of the
combination of the nutrition side of
things and like a dietitian
and a skilled therapist because
when we change anything with food i
immediately see mood
change and so sometimes it's at the
beginning of so someone comes in and
they're
deep in reoccurring binge eating
episodes we're going to try and
stabilize them
and regulate them their mood initially
would probably actually
feel like it would go um being worse and
that's because their copy strategies
taken away
so they need ways to kind of deal with
the emotional side of it
but once you get used to regulating mood
regulates because your brain starts to
find
other ways of coping and also trusts you
it starts to trust the fact that you can
give it consistent nutrition
over the course of the day and there
isn't going to be this large amount of
food at one day and then nothing nothing
nothing like nothing
large amount of food so it does regulate
your mood and your body has what it
needs
to regulate emotion and what are some of
the supports that you would offer or
recommend in these situations
so um it would definitely be a
exposure therapy almost is very
important um in
this kind of treatment so um meal plans
are very important
with binge eating recovery just as they
would be with someone who is suffering
with a very restrictive type of eating
disorder
meal plans are very very essential at
the beginning because it offers that
structure
it offers that baseline um and then some
exposure therapy so
the foods that they would use in their
benching episodes we'd have to find ways
to integrate them in a normal way
um little by little sprinkle them in and
a lot of support and accountability
because they're going to need they're
going to need it they're going to feel
like they're just
out of control that's where the
addiction kind of comes from they're
going to feel like
their vice has been taken away from them
and so they're going to need a lot of
support
and a lot of structure and
accountability is
the way to keep them really safe and
feeling like they can get through it
and just another kind of question off
what you just said because
one thing that i get asked a lot um and
i think that you'll be able to explain
this so nicely is for
for those who are struggling with an
eating disorder or disordered eating
who want to get to a point of intuitive
eating
but they don't have proper hunger and
fullness cues
why is that meal plan so important and
and you know what does that transition
look like from you know having being
really really deep in their eating
disorder to having some structure that
you'd be working with them one-on-one as
a dietitian
to moving towards a more of course a
more intuitive healthy relationship with
food fantastic question
the way that i like to describe it to my
clients is just the way that if you were
to break your arm and you would need a
cast
when you go into recovery the meal plan
is the cast we need it to hold you in
place while you heal
so because when you have a disorder
relationship with food or an eating
disorder
your hunger cues like you said are
completely broken and the only way to
fix them
is actually to mechanically get them
going again so that's where the meal
plan comes in
we mechanically start to jolt at first
it feels very
anti-intuition and it does you eat when
you're
not hungry you're always full um
it feels very opposite to what the
intuitive eating movement
uh you know praises but it's necessary
to just reset reset your system reset
your metabolism reset your hunger and
fullness cues
and then the way that we introduce it is
once essentially once the symptoms have
gone away so once you
um have a hold on your reoccurring benji
episodes or whatever the symptom is for
that
individual then we can start to play
around with okay
so you know we have this meal plan maybe
at one area of your meal plan
once a week we're gonna you're gonna try
and just uh
think about what you want to eat and go
with that so we just take
one area and practice using intuition
and see what happens because sometimes
we try that and the intuition doesn't
work their intuition says
that they should eat something that
their eating disorder would actually say
they have to eat so
we need to test whether their intuition
is is
real or if their eating disorder is
still controlling that
and that's where the eating the meal
plan is important because that just
holds it up that's back up
and then we just kind of pepper in some
intuitive eating here and there
um until we can sort of trust that you
trust your body and your body trusts
you to be able to just say okay i don't
need a meal plan
i can just choose as i want but that's
fantastic
that's so that you've you've really
explained it so beautifully because i
get asked this
in dms every single day saying i want to
eat
intuitively but i don't have hunger and
fullness cues
and should i just eat what i want and
what i feel like
you may not be ready for that yet
absolutely absolutely in fact
you probably aren't ready for it and it
should
and there shouldn't be a timeline of
okay so like a month of mechanical
eating and then intuitive eating there
is
it isn't really that kind of dry
sometimes it's that quick but oftentimes
um i see months months of mechanical
eating
before you can sort of have that
intuition come back
and it's usually relative to how long
you've been disordered right so if you
had
years of disordered eating your hunger
cues are going to take some time to come
back and sometimes it can take even up
to a year
so people think oh my gosh it's not
working i'm going to give up i'm going
to go straight to intuition give it the
time because once you have it
you have it and then you can be
intuitive for the rest of your life it
just might mean you might need to be
mechanical for
months a year and is weight rest
restoration a
um like a key determinant of whether or
not somebody's ready to kind of move on
or is it mainly based on
so you want to also make sure that they
are in a healthy place physically as
well
exactly exactly so everybody's a little
bit different if weight restoration is a
part of their
plan then that absolutely needs to be
at the priority um because it's hard to
manage you know there's like set point
there's also this
you know back and forth between like set
point and disordered eating did you ruin
your set point
what if i don't like my set point so a
lot of work has to be done to just
say okay we need to just restore and
again do the meal plan let's put the
cast on let's try and heal you
first and then let's kind of see where
where things
are um but yeah you have the weight
restore first
before you can even think about being
intuitive because sometimes your
intuition
impacts weight restoration unfortunately
oh for sure
absolutely oh well i could talk to you
all day and i'm sure that we will have
other videos where i have
really great pointed questions to to get
into all those topics um but forever
but for everyone who's watching at home
please leave um a comment if
if you want to hear some other great
insights from alessandra and we'll
we'll have her on again for another
video um but thank you
so much for your time i hope you stay
in these crazy coke times
i'm sure we'll be in touch again soon
okay thank you thank you so much
thank you again alessandra that was so
so helpful
um i'm gonna be leaving some links below
to some places that you can reach
alessandra for some one-on-one support
so to round out this review i want to
once again say that the intention
for this video is not to diagnose or
pathologize nicocado avocado
but rather i just want to use this as
discussion
on some not uncommon food behaviors
and the potential physical and emotional
implications
that they may have i also want to
strongly remind you to please
be kind in the comments both here and on
nick's channel
we ultimately cannot know what somebody
might be going through behind the scenes
but by considering the research and what
we're seeing
in clinical settings what we can say
is our relationship with food goes
far beyond our physical health as there
does
appear to be a strong connection between
food and what we eat
and our emotions and this is definitely
important to consider in the age of
kovid when
let's be real our mental and emotional
well-beings
may require a little bit more nurturing
and care
and on that note that is all for today's
video folks
if you liked it please be sure to give
it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have any
questions or anyone else or any channels
that you want to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you